Guayaquil una ciudad asediada por la
violencia del narcotráfico durante la
madrugada del domingo una balacera entre
bandas criminales que se disputan el
control territorial de esta ciudad
costera una posición que le convierte en
un punto estratégico en la ruta del
narcotráfico dejó 10 muertos y al menos
tres heridos entre ellos una niña de 5
años creemos que se trata de una lucha
de los grupos delincuenciales
organizados esto es por la lucha por el
poder por el territorio por apropiarse
de los de los diferentes actividades
ilícitas según las pesquisas policiales
una camioneta con varios sujetos
desconocidos realizaron varias
detonaciones con armas largas Este es el
segundo ataque armado en menos de un mes
las autoridades y fuerzas de seguridad
han intensificado sus operaciones
militares en las zonas más conflictivas
para hacer frente a los atentados
secuestros y asesinatos en sus calles
que dejan el la zozobra a los habitantes
de Guayaquil en ello como Ciudadana
de
de vivir así con esta inseguridad
lamento mucho lo que está sucediendo en
mi país No podemos salir con nuestra
familia nuestros hijos a ningún lado
desde el 1 de abril la ciudad se
encuentra bajo el estado de emergencia
debido a la inseguridad y la violencia
con 770 homicidios en lo que va de año